- Welcome back to a special hour y'all.
We are unlocking our vault to showcase
amazing interview moments
you've never seen before.
And today it's all about perfect pairs.
(upbeat rock music)
All right, all right.
Um, I count actors Ed
Helms and Randall Park
among the best of them.
They were here promoting their show,
"True Story With Ed and Randall,"
and we decided to mix
things up and take advantage
of the sunny weather here
in Southern California
by bringing our conversation to the roof.
One thing we quickly learned
is we all had in common,
it was classic TV,
so just take a look.
Uh, but Randall you've said
that you were raised by TV,
which I feel like a
lot of us kind of were,
I was raised by a single
mom for a lot of my life,
so I literally was in
front of a TV as well.
Do you feel like, what
sitcoms kind of raised you?
- Oh my gosh. I was, I grew up on, on,
I knew every sitcom, like on the schedule
and, and my entire like outlook
on real life was just like
based on the stories in these sitcoms.
- Yeah.
- Uh, there, uh, one of my
favorites was "Silver Spoons."
Remember "Silver Spoons"?
- Yeah, of course.
- Ricky Schroder.
- [Kelly] No way. I don't know that one.
- Oh, you're too young.
- [Kelly] Okay dang.
- Yeah, you're too young.
- [Kelly] Oh, I was like ...
- Stream it. Is it streaming?
- This is what we're learning.
- [Ed] That's all you could do now.
- [Randall] "Family Ties."
- "Family Ties." I love "Family Ties."
- Great. Great. Yeah. All of 'em.
- Mine was like "Cosby Show,"
like "Designing Women."
And "I Love Lucy."
Like "I Love Lucy" was my,
that was like one of my favorite things
that my mom probably thought I was weird.
All my friends were playing
and I was like, "no, it's on."
- It's the best.
- [Kelly] I was like, I loved her.
- "Dick Van Dyke Show." Another one.
- "Chips"?
- [Kelly] "Chips." I saw "Chips."
- I liked "Chips."
- [Kelly] I don't know
that it raised me, but yes.
- All right. All right. Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- I dunno. Um.
- [Randall] You were, Ed
was raised by "Chips."
- I'm just trying, I'm
just trying to participate.
- I shouldn't own this
and we might cut this out
but I did once get pulled over in LA,
this was like 15 years ago
and I wasn't doing anything.
And this guy on a
motorcycle and it was like,
even his horn was sad,
it was a sad cop sound,
like it was like, it was like, beep beep,
and it was like a banana
seat bike, like horn.
It was weird.
And he pulled me over and he was like,
he just acted like such a jerk.
And I was like, okay "Chips,"
has it been a hard day?
And I ...
- [Randall] You said "Chips"?
(Ed and Kelly laugh)
- Cause I was like, you
just totally pulled me over
for half my taillight being out like
and giving me a ticket?
Like, you didn't even gimme a warning?
- [Randall] Did he respond to "Chips"?
- Pretty sure I got the ticket
because I called him "Chips."
- He's like you're coming downtown.
- Yeah. But he was so mean and
I was so lovely at the time
cause I was like, "oh, I'm
so sorry. What was I doing?"
And then just proceeded to
act like such a mean person.
Anyway.
- Yeah. Don't, don't call a cop "Chips."
- [Kelly] I called him "Chips."
- [Ed] Yeah.
- It was worth the ticket.
(Ed, Kelly and Randall laugh)
I'll tell you what, I'd
pay it all over again.
It was, he was not nice and
most cops are nice for me.
Whatever. Not that I get
pulled over a lot. What?
Um.
(Ed, Kelly and Randall laugh)
In my twenties.
Did y'all ever work in
the food service industry?
I was a waitress. I feel like
all of us have been waiters
or some form of food industry.
I'm gonna ask you questions
right before you shoveled
soup in your mouth,
just to make it real fun and
exciting and challenging.
I hope you have pepper in your teeth.
- Should I talk with like tons of, of peas
like falling outta my mouth?
(Kelly and Randall laugh)
- Um, I'll go first.
- Well, I, I'll tell you about mine.
No.
(Kelly and Ed laugh)
- [Kelly] It was all I (indistinct)
- That was. I can't tell
if that was funny or not.
- [Randall] Probably disturbing, yeah.
- It was awesome.
- Um, I worked in a
concession stand at like
our little community, like, pool area.
And um,
it was a very,
like, not notable experience
other than the fact that
the whole point of the job for us
as like, cause I think I
was 13 or 14 when I started.
- Oh wow.
- We would put, we just would
sabotage the next person
in the sh, who's, whoever
had the next shift.
So like, if I was closing
at night, I would put like
cups of nacho cheese on the ceiling fan,
so that when the person
came in the next morning
and then they'd like, be like
a tornado of nacho cheese
that they'd have to clean up.
And that's what we did do each other.
- And probably bugs. Because it attracted?
- Oh. Oh, just a million
health code violations.
(Kelly, Randall and crew laugh)
Yeah. But, but it was
so fun to just like mess
with the each other.
Cause you'd have like 45
minutes to open and you got,
it's like, "oh, okay, what
am I cleaning up today?"
- Oh my gosh.
I hope they got you back.
Um, my first job was a movie theater.
So I worked concessions,
in like, box office.
We used to do this thing where it's like,
I mean I'm telling myself, but
you could only eat the damaged candy,
if somebody brought back and
it was like a damaged box.
So like sometimes we would just like
chunk a Hot Tamales box on the ground.
And be like, "oh my gosh,
that is so damaged."
- What happened to this box?
- And then we'd eat it. Yes.
So, it's bad to work in that environment.
Even if it's just eating a bunch of stuff
you wouldn't have eaten
cause you're bored.
- Yeah.
- You guys are wild.
(Kelly laughs)
So I worked at a Starbucks.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And this is like not too long ago.
Uh, and you know what we used to do,
we used to pee in the coffee.
- [Kelly] What?
- I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
(Randall laughs)
I'm joking.
- Oh my god. Everyone's freaking out
in a drive-through of Starbucks right now.
- We didn't, no, we didn't do that.
I just tried to one up you
guys and it didn't work.
Um.
No, uh.
- You're gonna to get sued anyway.
Even though, even
though, you were kidding.
- Make it a great story. Yeah.
- No, I worked at a Starbucks.
I was, I was just started acting
so I needed a job that was flexible,
allowed me to audition, and Starbucks was,
it was one of my favorite
jobs. And I remember,
I worked at the one, uh,
in the Palisades and you know,
fancy people lived there.
And I remember, uh one day, again,
I'm a struggling actor,
uh ,Brad Garrett came in
and I was like, "oh my
God, that's Brad Garrett."
And he was just as tall as you'd expect.
And he had this booming voice and, uh,
and he left a, a $20 tip.
- [Kelly] Oh that's nice.
- Which was really sweet.
- I promised myself that
whenever I was a waiter
that I would tip well.
- [Randall] Yes.
- I was like, anytime I go
somewhere, if I ever make money,
I'm gonna tip well because
sometimes you work your tail
off and yeah, you get nothing.
- Oh yeah. Yeah, for sure.
- I was like, I won't be that tool.